- All right, so the Tesla Cybertruck
has been kind of an enigma.
It was revealed four years
ago, almost to the day,
and ever since then it was kind of quiet.
But then we slowly started
seeing them rolling
around like California a little bit
and then a couple in Texas.
And these were like prototype Cybertrucks,
and they were testing.
Turns out one of them was me.
Well, for a day anyway.
So what we have here is a
near final Tesla Cybertruck.
It's not an actual delivery truck yet.
It's still one that they've been testing.
So there's some small, small prototyping
things here or there,
but everything that I'm about to show you
is what's going to show up in
the customer's delivery trucks
starting basically right now.
So I've learned a lot about this truck
in my time testing it.
There are some surprising things about it,
some features that are really cool,
things that I think truck
people are really gonna like,
but also some concerns that
I have, some surprises.
Buckle up is gonna be a mega video.
Get subscribed.
There's a lot to it.
Let's take a look at the
final Tesla Cybertruck.
(upbeat music)
(wipers squeaking)
All right, first things
first, let's get to the specs.
Everyone wants to know
the official numbers.
Everything on paper.
And it's funny because we'll
get to this in a second,
but some things have actually changed
from the show truck
that showed up on stage,
including the overall dimensions.
I'll get to that.
But the stuff that you probably care about
is the basics like price,
range, speed, right?
So there are gonna be three configurations
of the Cybertruck.
This one that we're looking at here,
which you can't tell by looking at it,
but this is the triple motor version.
It's not quite the same
as the Plaid powertrain,
but it is two in the
rear, one in the front
and it's gonna be able to
do zero to 60 in 2.7 seconds
and 11 second quarter mile.
It's got about 845 horsepower.
It has torque vectoring at the rear
and it's absurd.
They call it the beast.
It's a pretty ridiculous set of specs.
I think that makes it
the fastest production
pickup truck factory ever.
But there's also going to
be a dual motor version
that they also start to ship early
and eventually also a single
motor real wheel drive version.
The triple motor is gonna start
at about a hundred thousand dollars.
So this is new information.
We kind of had a much lower idea
of what the price is gonna be at launch.
This is a hundred thousand
dollars truck you're looking at,
expect somewhere around 75, 85,000
for the dual motor version.
And then the single motor
will be further down the road.
But the dual motor is
still 600 plus horsepower
and still plenty fast.
But that's the general basics.
And as far as range,
we'll get to the wheels in a second,
but it's about a 340 mile max range
from the absolute most
efficient version of this truck.
Now a couple other last numbers.
Things that I think some
truck people will appreciate.
First of all, towing
capacity and bed capacity.
Those are some things
that Tesla's told me.
I'm gonna put the numbers up here.
I think it's 2,500 pounds for
the bed, which is pretty cool.
And we also measured the truck,
because officially it's about 5% smaller
in every dimension from
the original show truck,
the prototype that people
have been seeing on stage.
So I measure it from front to back
and it's about from bumper
to bumper, 224 inches.
We happen to have an F-150 Lightning here
that we've been directly
comparing it to right over there.
We've got some onboard power
and all sorts of fun features here.
And so I'll mention when things like
that also appear on this truck,
but it's about the size
of an F-150 Lightning
A little bit smaller.
Now speaking of the 5%
shrinking dimension wise,
there are a lot of things that
have changed about this truck
versus the original show car.
From front to back there's a lot.
There's a motorized front trunk,
there's so much to talk
about in this video.
There is the world's
largest windshield wiper,
which I'm sure you're curious about.
So we'll talk about that.
It does actually have side view mirrors.
They're removable and they've kind of done
all that they possibly can to
make it able to be removed.
Like you can take this off,
it has to ship with this
from the factory legally.
But there is a blind
spot monitoring lights
inside the truck.
There are cameras here
on the side of the truck
to show you that spot when
you put your blinker on.
So you can just pop this
off if you really wanted to.
And then also down at the
side here, these wheels,
this is an arrow cap that is removable.
So let's just do that to start.
This is the premium tire
that's going to come
on a 20 inch rim.
All of the initial trucks,
triple motor, dual motor,
they'll all have this tire on.
It looks like it's a
bespoke Goodyear tire.
It's got some neat little aesthetic tweaks
and I'm sure compound
tweaks and tread stuff here.
But this is a plastic arrow cap
with like this outside rubber.
It's actually a two piece
and it'll get you a couple
percent more range on the truck,
but if you don't like the look of it
or if you're off-roading, pop that off.
And that's how the truck's
stock wheel will look.
A lot of grease and metal in there.
But this is a two part thing like I said.
So if I can rip this off,
these are the two pieces
and the reason is two parts
is because actually
one of these to line up
with the little rectangles on the tire.
So maybe you want to
take the arrow caps off
to air down the tires and go off-roading
and you want maximum brake
cooling, whatever you're doing.
But if you wanna put these back on,
you sort of line all this up
(cap clanging)
and then you take the plastic bit,
now you're back.
Get a shot of this, get a shot of my,
so I'm gonna probably not do that again
considering everything
it just left on my hands.
But you get the idea, you can
do that on all four tires,
20 inch rims.
These again are the premium tires
and yeah, okay, great, moving on.
So okay, you kind of can't
really tell the story
of the Cybertruck without
addressing the fact
that it is a giant
stainless steel triangle.
I mean it looks surreal.
Like there is not really a single curve
on this entire truck.
Every single piece,
these are giant pieces of stainless steel.
There's all sorts of sheen
and fingerprint implications
that we'll talk about,
but I don't know it's an aesthetic thing,
like not a whole lot of curves.
Fine, that's pretty cool.
But then the other version
of that conversation
is like look at how
sharp the front of the,
some of these pieces
here, how sharp it is.
Not that you're gonna like walk up
and poke the front of
someone's truck very often,
but that's a sharp corner piece
of stainless steel right
there and right there.
And then this front piece here,
it's this one huge big stamped piece
and I had a couple
conversations with people,
engineers at Tesla about
using stainless steel
on the body panels like this.
And they have these huge presses
that are stamping the stainless steel,
but steel has this sort
of a spring back effect.
So you use a lot of force
to stamp it in place,
but then it springs back really quickly.
So you have to stamp further than you need
to get it to unspring back to the part
that you want it to be at.
It's a whole complicated thing.
All of that is to say,
I've seen a bunch of
Cybertrucks while I've been here
and they all have
slightly different levels
of panel gaps, build quality in general.
This truck in particular
that we're looking at,
it actually looks great.
I'm not gonna say it's
micron levels of precision
or anything like that,
but generally panel
gaps all the way around
are pretty small, pretty
even, looks really good.
But I don't know, I don't
know if I can promise that
for every truck, like even
just this huge front piece here
has a little bit of like wavering.
It's not quite a perfect flat line.
So I'm not an expert on it,
but I'm just saying this is a truck,
you're probably not gonna
care too much about looking
exactly perfect panel gap wise.
All right, the next
thing we gotta talk about
is the Cybertrucks trunk,
AKA, the truck bed.
There's a lot going on here, actually.
Look at this gigantic slope.
It kind of, it looks
like a dump truck to me.
But one thing you should
know is first of all,
a dampened opening for the tailgate,
but it's not a power opening tailgate.
So you will have to
manually close the thing,
but it is a nice soft damp.
And then the other side is
the powered tonneau cover.
Oh wait, I should do the thing.
They told me it could
support up to 300 pounds.
So...
They told me I could
do it, so here we are.
I'm not gonna jump, but I'm
told 300 pounds of force
from somebody standing on one foot.
So I think if I jumped I could
probably break the thing.
But the fact that I'm standing on it
and it's not breaking, that's pretty good.
And it's a motorized tonneau cover,
which means...
Pretty smooth, I gotta say.
Now once you're here,
there's a bunch of stuff
I gotta talk about with this trunk.
First things first, you
probably notice it slid down
and revealed a rear window,
which means number one,
yes, there's a rear window.
It doesn't go up and down,
but at least you have that glass there.
And two, yes, that means
that when you close the tonneau cover
you are completely blocking
your rear visibility.
We'll get to that later.
So the other thing you probably noticed
is when we first saw the Cybertruck,
I did a video about this
on the auto-focus channel.
The bed was just like
bare stainless steel.
It looked kind of sick, it looked crazy,
but you'll notice now it is fully lined.
Tesla said they took it out
and talked to some
construction people about it
and were like, "All right, what
do you think of this truck?
"What do you think of the bed?"
And they were like, "This is awesome.
"But the first thing I
would do is spray line this
"so I could not damage it."
So they just figured they
would line it themselves.
Nice thick lining here.
The bed size, the official
length of the bed for the F-150,
the lightning got over there
was 66 inches on paper.
Now when I line this up here,
I get all the way to 72 inches.
So it's a solid six foot bed,
but there's a little bit
of overhang over here.
So if I subtract a little
bit to account for that,
it's about the same 66 inches.
And there's a little bit of a sub trunk,
which is pretty cool to see.
So a lot of EVs now have
sort of a sub trunk area.
This one no different.
You can definitely fit
duffel bag in there,
probably a full carry-on bag
and there is a drain plug,
so if you wanna make a cooler out of it
and tailgate it's a pretty
good vehicle to do that.
There's also some bed lighting you can see
on the left and right.
There's lots of lights
and there's also this
sort of a latch system.
So all sorts of latch points
where you can tie things down with cables.
What you're probably noticing though is
there's no spare tire, no spare wheel.
If you do want one, you
can buy one separately
and tie it up in the trunk but
you don't get one by default.
And then the other thing is
there's power in the trunk.
So two 120 volts here and one 240 volt.
If you want to charge a vehicle
with a nine kilowatts out,
you can use literally the thing
you'd plug into a dryer outlet.
You can plug that in here,
plug it into a vehicle
and give battery to another EV.
So just in general, I'm glad
that more EVs are doing this,
having the ability to power other things
and actually charge.
You could actually theoretically
power your house with this
if you have the right inverter,
but 11 kilowatts out of the charge port,
9.6 kilowatts out of the 240 volt onboard.
All great stuff to have.
I should also mention small detail,
bottle cap opener over there
and then some more mounting points
for cables and things like that.
That's the truck bed of the Cybertruck.
There's some lights that
we'll talk about in a second,
but let's close the tonneau cover.
Oh, something I just noticed.
If you press the button,
it does the whole thing
or if you hold the button,
it goes until you let go.
That's a lie.
It was doing that up until that point.
See wait, okay, this is weird.
It didn't do it that time,
but it seems like if I hold it down,
whenever I let go, it stops,
and if I just press
it, it goes all the way
until I cancel it,
which it doesn't wanna cancel over there.
Okay, I'm learning in real time.
Close the whole thing.
Tell me when to cancel.
I knew it.
Alright, we gotta talk about these doors,
'cause there's actually a lot to it.
So first of all, a lot
of times on a concept car
or a prototype, you'll see
there's no door handles
and you're like, oh, that's cute.
But when you ship the thing,
you're gonna have door handles eventually.
No door handles on the cyber truck
and they're sticking to it.
I have my concerns about this.
So basically how this works
is there's a little button
right here that's indented.
You press that button
and when it's unlocked
it sort of pushes it out maybe two inches.
Then you grab in here
and open the whole door
and then you close it.
(door slamming)
The auto presented windows,
they all close themselves up here,
they're frameless windows.
That's cool.
It works.
Same thing actually back here.
Smaller button.
You press it, it opens it and it works.
And this is actually
a full 90 degree door.
I love that there's like
stainless steel in here.
It's very clearly all metal.
(door slamming)
It's got a nice thunk to it too.
But what I've noticed,
and this is something you'd
already be thinking of
if you live in the northeast or something,
is if it's cold, or if it's raining
or if it's frozen,
if there's like an inch of ice over here,
is this gonna work?
Tesla's telling me, and this is a,
this is a California company
that tells me these things,
but they're telling me
up to an inch of ice.
If you can break through that ice
and press this button,
it'll push with enough force
to open it and break the ice off.
I hope that's true.
That's debatable, we'll see.
But the other thing about that
is I think a lot of people
are going to open it down
here on the stainless steel
(door slamming)
and you can see the
fingerprints go so hard
when you open it like that.
And because there's no door handles,
there's not really a good way
of telling someone how to get in.
So a lot of people are just
gonna grab it right there
and fingerprint, look at,
there's just tons of fingerprints
on the side here.
So I don't know, there's
gonna be a lot of Cybertrucks
floating around with lots of fingerprints
around the place that people's
hands go to open the doors.
All right, front of the truck here.
Couple things that are of note.
First of all, if we go down low,
this plastic bumper pretty solid,
but also there's two tow
hitch rigs on the front,
which is awesome.
There is a front camera for
the first time ever in a Tesla,
believe it or not.
It's useful on a truck like this
where you can't actually
see over the front.
Then you have this huge
daytime running light,
but also the headlights,
the actual headlights
are just these slots down here.
I'll show some night, you'll
see some night driving footage.
So you'll see what the
headlights look like.
But then the thing
everybody's been asking about
and I've seen mostly on Twitter
is there actually a front trunk in here?
If so, how big is it?
Yes, there's a front trunk
and it's automatically opening
so you just reach in and push the button
in like that and it's a
pretty shallow front trunk,
I gotta say.
This is also the part
where I feel compelled
to mention that I haven't
seen a single Tesla logo yet
on this entire truck.
It's mostly branded with Cybertruck
in this kind of a welded
text, which is kind of cool,
but it's a pretty shallow front trunk.
I mean I can sit in here
and you're probably seeing
much too shaded right now,
so it's kind of tough to
understand how big it is,
but it's only maybe the size of two
of these Ridge suitcases.
So I'm gonna put two Ridge carry-ons
in the front of this thing,
see if I can actually fit both.
'Cause this is basically the exact size
you'd want for like an airplane overhead.
If you actually had to travel
with stuff in the front
trunk, could you fit it?
(alarm beeping quietly)
Not quite, it's really close.
I think maybe you might
have to do some Jenga
(suitcases shuffling)
to turn them down.
As long as they're behind this seal
I think I'm good.
Take two.
(trunk clicking)
Okay, so that's basically your exact limit
is two Ridge carry-ons.
Shout out to Ridge for
sponsoring this video.
So these Ridge carry-ons which
are in these nice colors.
They also have a 30% thicker shell
than a standard carry on
while staying lightweight.
Some nice carbon fiber accents,
a durable and grippy handle
and they're weatherproof.
So wherever you go, if
it's raining, you're good.
And if you want a matching Ridge wallet,
it literally comes in the same colors.
So you've got Royal black,
Alpine Navy, Basecamp Orange
and Matte olive.
And shout out to Ridge for offering
a 99 day risk-free trial.
So if you don't like it for
any reason within 99 days,
you can literally send it back
for a refund, no questions asked.
So check out the bags, the wallets
and everything else Ridge makes
and get a special offer at my link below
or at ridge.com/mkbhd.
Alright, so now let's get to the interior
(door banging)
of the Cybertruck.
And once again, there's a lot going on,
but I think probably the
first thing you notice
is the only curve in the entire interior
is this steering wheel.
And yes, it's a wheel, it's not a yolk.
I'm pretty sure when they
first showed the car,
one of the big things they showed was
it had a yolk and it had
this crazy like marble shelf
at the front.
Now it's looking a lot
more normal car-like,
but there are still a lot to go over.
So first of all, this glass,
this glass canopy from the
nose of the car basically
all the way back to
right in front of my head
is the single largest piece of glass
in the entire automotive industry.
Like if you tried to order
a piece of glass this big
for a house would be a big piece of glass.
But this is the biggest
windshield we've ever seen.
And it kind of is this
nice dramatic canopy
when you're just like looking around
and visibility in the truck is very good.
You also have these
little removable sunshades
that are actually pretty big
and there's this nice, look
at this magnetic connector
(connector clicking)
up top to get that in place.
So that's cool and everything.
But aside from that, no other curves.
Lots of straight angles and
triangles and things like that.
A good amount of door storage.
So I think you could fit probably
two water bottles in there.
There's some tray storage up here.
Then you get up to here
and there's all four window controls,
the door latch to electronically open it,
but also the emergency door latch open.
So if you lose power every door
that's electronically latched
has to have that manual opening as well.
And then in the middle
you've got just kind of
a bunch of open space.
I kind of like the pedals down there.
I think they're metal.
But then you have just
this big open tray space,
which I believe the Rivian also has.
And then in front two wireless chargers,
two cup holders, a big
old armrest in the middle
and a bunch of storage in here,
including another 120 volt outlet
and a single 65 watt USBC charging port.
And then you're sort of in the cabin
and this is where I
think you kind of return
to the normal Tesla look,
which is very minimal.
I do like this material better
than what they had before,
though it's not the
best build in the world.
Tesla's been improving
with their build quality,
but it is what it is.
But you can literally,
you can like lose
something in front of you.
Like if I put like a, like
a marble or a pizza box
or something it, it could slide forward.
Of course I could
accelerate and get it back,
but there's just a ton of room.
And then I'm thinking about visibility
over the nose of the car.
Man, it's not great.
I feel like the more I drive this car,
the more I get accustomed
to the size of it.
But I really don't feel like
I'm looking right down over the nose.
I'm looking out at the
end of the windshield
and then sort of guessing
where the nose is.
So, okay, a couple of the smaller things.
First of all, this light up here,
touch sensitive, I think
that's pretty cool.
There's ambient lights all
the way around the cabin
and you can change the color
of that with RGB with software.
I'll get to the software in a second.
There's also an interior
facing cabin camera
and there would normally be,
this is one of the prototyping things,
but there would normally be a
regular rear view camera here.
Now as I mentioned, you
don't actually get to see
out the back from the
mirror if your tonneau cover
is closed, but there
also is no camera option
for that rear view mirror to
turn into a feed from a camera
instead that will always be on the screen.
And I think I've found that
that's, it's actually fine.
You just sort of train yourself
to glance at the top of the screen
instead of at where
the mirror normally is.
But that's something to note.
And one more thing, what was I gonna say?
Oh yeah, huge tinted roof over your head,
all the way back over
the passenger's heads
and a ton of speakers.
Not a single curve to any
of the speaker grills,
but there are speaker
grills all over this cabin
and they're all either
trapezoids or squares.
Okay, something I've just realized,
I thought that it was required
that the only actual physical button
you need in your car
is the hazards button.
This truck does not have a hazards button,
it has a touch sensitive hazards thing.
But then there's also your park, reverse,
neutral and drive gears
if you actually wanna change them
up above your head.
I've never seen that there're
in any car, ever actually.
Typically it's right in front of you
with the paddles shifters
or your gear selectors
and you can still do it on the screen
like you can in other Teslas.
But that, that's new.
That's definitely new.
Okay, now the backseat of the Cybertruck,
it's weirder than you think.
All right, first of all,
I like that the door's open 90 degrees,
you get the seat back in front of you,
really good rear leg room.
Mostly because the seat in front of me
is on these cool Cybertruck
looking rectangular risers.
But that means I have real space
to put my feet under
the seat in front of me,
which is huge for leg room.
So either side, totally fine, middle,
not the best leg room ever,
but still a totally great backseat.
Got another screen back here
that I'll show you in a second.
There's a little bit of seat back storage,
but check this out.
There's a little trick to the back seat.
Just for storage, so although you already
have a front trunk and a rear trunk,
if you want even more covered storage
with this latch right here,
the right seat actually
comes completely up
and you can just keep stuff down here
if there's no person here.
Matter of fact, the left
two seats come over here,
also do the same thing.
I'm gonna get out and
pull that latch as well.
And then that's just, that's
a ton of room for activities.
Look at this, not that that's
better than having a seat,
but you could put a
bunch of boxes back here.
You could put, I don't know,
you could just put stuff back here.
Also, there's the nine
and a half inch screen
for the passengers, which
is where I discovered
you can move the passenger seat,
not the driver's seat on the screen.
And these are also heated
left and right, not middle,
but heated, left and right rear seats.
They look ventilated, they look cool,
but they don't do that.
Just heat.
Or you could just like watch a movie
or direct your airflow.
Cool.
Okay, so whenever you're talking about
a new vehicle like this,
a new platform like this,
you gotta talk vehicle controls.
So as I'm in the driver's seat,
that's gonna be this new 18
and a half inch touchscreen
in the center, biggest ever in a Tesla.
It's also the biggest ever car.
And this steering wheel, which
I got a lot to say about it,
but you're gonna notice
it looks pretty familiar
to any other Tesla.
But they have made some key changes
that I think I actually like a lot.
There's still no stalks,
there's still no blinker stalks,
still no drive, reverse, all that stuff.
But the buttons on the steering wheel
are at least now haptic
like actual buttons.
They're not haptic touch controls
where you touch it and it
vibrates to simulate a button.
Now it actually clicks
and moves this time.
So that's awesome.
So at least that's better.
So that's the blinkers
on the steering wheel.
That's your headlights.
That's your giant windshield wiper,
which I'll talk about.
And your voice controls,
you still got your wheels up and down
for volume of media and
your autopilot controls.
And then this sort of a flat squirkle,
I guess is what you'd call it,
like a squared off circle type
thing for the steering wheel.
Oh, and then
(horn honking)
it's a real horn this time.
There's no like button on
the steering wheel horn
like in my car.
So I really appreciate that.
Also, again, no Tesla logo
on the steering wheel.
It's a Cybertruck like
trapezoid silhouette type thing.
So again, I think the only
Tesla logo in the whole car
is literally the key,
same as every other Tesla.
But that brings us of
course to the new software.
So I think they've done an
actually really, really good job
with the software in
this all new cyber UI.
So, if you've used a Tesla before,
it's laid out the exact same way,
but it's all themed in
a very Cybertruck way.
But there's some new little
things that they've done.
It's really well thought out.
And I still honestly, after using it,
I really feel like Tesla
has the best software
in the car industry that's
not CarPlay and Android Auto.
So first of all, you start
with just this huge Cybertruck
in the middle for all
your vehicle controls.
There's little hovering dots.
So if you want to open the tailgate
or open the Tonneau cover, you can do that
with any of these little hovering buttons.
Open the charge port flap,
charge port flap, cool.
But then all of the rest
of the looks about the car,
you can adjust in real time.
So first of all, ride height,
you tap the wheel there
we are at the sort of a entry ride height
where it squats to be as
easy as possible to get into.
You can also go low, medium or high
and it adjusts super fast.
There's a pretty awesome 12
inches of suspension travel
between the lowest mode
and the highest mode.
You can go all the way up to 17 inches
of clearance in off-road mode.
Extract mode is the absolute highest.
It'll add another 80
millimeters of clearance,
but it'll go a foot down from that.
So that's pretty sick.
And there are aluminum skid plates
slash aero shields at
the bottom of the truck.
I continue to move around.
If I lower the window, for example,
look at the window on the car,
halfway down, halfway down.
I go all the way down on this window,
all the way down on that window.
So that's real time.
I get my lights in real time.
I have the headlights down here.
If I even turn the steering wheel,
all of that moves in real time.
And it's kind of on
this like Mars terrain,
cyber terrain, whatever you wanna call it.
I think that's sweet.
So you just get a full
overview of the car there.
If you've got your media, your navigation,
it's telling me if I need to close my door
or fasten my seatbelt,
and this is my range indicator up here,
223 miles right now, which
if I tap it is 76% battery,
pretty close to what I'm expecting.
And then you see your navigation,
which basically if you just swipe over,
you can fill that right
two thirds of the screen
with navigation and keep your
vehicle controls on the left.
And when you're in drive,
that looks just like it
normally does in a Tesla
with other stuff on the road.
But now you have all
your navigation stuff.
You always have all your stuff in the dock
down at the bottom,
heated steering wheel with two levels,
which is nice now and your
heated and cooled front seats,
which is great.
So if you just get into
controls and dynamics,
these are sort of the two spaces
you'll spend the most time.
Controls is all of the things
with just opening and closing,
unlocking screen brightness, headlights,
your glove box is a drawer,
which I think is a little bit unique,
a button on the screen.
I kind of wish you still had a
button to open the glove box.
But all of that is here.
And then dynamics is where you have all
of your typical like steering
and acceleration profiles for Tesla.
So in the triple motor version,
that would be comfort mode,
standard mode and beast mode,
little cringey I guess.
But that is your maximum acceleration
and then your ride and handling
and your preferred ride height.
If you go custom, you can actually
individually adjust these things.
So acceleration, I'm gonna go beast mode,
but ride and handling,
maybe you want it to be
a little more relaxed
or a little more focused.
That just basically means your damping
and your suspension is
either a little firmer
or a little softer.
I gotta say though, the
steering is, in my opinion,
the craziest thing about
the Tesla Cybertruck.
Crazier than the design,
crazier than the dimensions,
crazier than everything else
about it is the steering.
So it's a steer by wire system.
This is the first time Tesla's done this.
You can't actually change
the steering weight
or steering feel.
It's always the same ratio all the time.
But it's crazy for two reasons.
One, there is rear axle steering
and it is very, very
active and really helpful.
And two is the total turn
is less than 180 degrees
for your maximum tightest turn.
Usually you're used to doing
a whole bunch of movement on the wheel.
You don't have to do that anymore.
So that kind of makes the muscle memory
of grabbing the top of
the squirkle useless.
So first of all, the rear
wheel steer, it's awesome.
It's up to 10 degrees in
the opposite direction
of the front wheels.
At low speeds under 40 miles an hour.
And what that does, if
you've heard of this before,
it effectively shortens the wheel base
and allows you to turn way, way tighter.
I think we'll do a sort of a comparison
with the F-150 Lightning,
which is a normal truck that doesn't have
10 degrees of rear wheel steer.
And this one, it just means
you can turn way sharper.
It feels way more nimble in parking lots.
It feels like it shrinks the wheel base,
the whole dimensions of the truck.
It's great, it takes some getting used to,
but it's very useful.
And then at higher speeds
above 40 miles an hour
is when it actually
changes one or two degrees
in the same direction as the front wheel.
So that's gonna feel more like
lengthening the wheel base
and a more stable movement
changing between lanes at
highway speed, stuff like that.
But the fact that your
entire steering radius
is right there in less than one turn,
like half a turn, is crazy.
It takes some getting used to.
It is awesome that you
can turn around so easily
and make those tight parking lot maneuvers
and make this big truck feel smaller.
But it is, it's really, it's a lot.
It's gonna take some getting used to,
but I think we should just
get to driving this thing.
So let's do it.
Let's drive the Cybertruck.
All right, driving the Tesla Cybertruck.
Feels like a Doug Miro
way to start the video,
but man, okay, it still
doesn't really feel
like a real vehicle, but it definitely is.
And first impression really is,
well okay, it feels like a Tesla.
That's not gonna be a shocker.
Really instant throttle response.
This is the triple motor
version, it's the beast.
But also like spacing wise.
I'm just looking around,
just trying to feel how
big this vehicle is.
This is a small road, school bus.
I'm able to maneuver around though.
I have pretty good visibility everywhere.
I'm just thinking a lot about
where the nose of the truck is,
because it is such a short nose.
It's a really different, different ratio.
I'm not used to the hood being that short
compared to where the windshield is,
but either way it's pretty quiet.
I will say these laminated
windows do a good job
of sealing out all the noise.
They also happen to be shatterproof.
The truck also happens to
be allegedly bulletproof.
I'm not testing that in this video,
but you've seen the pictures.
So the idea is it's really well built.
I'm just trying to figure out,
all right, this feels nimble, right?
Steering is the way it's not gonna change.
So this is the way it always is.
Getting used to the
steering is really gonna be
the number one thing for people.
They're not gonna be used to
the entire steering being
less than an entire turn.
It's a half a turn, 180
degrees, I think it's 170,
and it is a pretty big truck,
but it's, I feel like
it's a tiny bit smaller
than the F-150 Lightning.
I think they did a good job
of giving you as much space as you can.
Like this is a spacious cabin,
spacious back seats as I showed you,
and a full six foot bed.
But it's got the smallest front.
Even smaller than the smaller Rivian R1T.
So they've kind of pushed around
the dimensions a little bit.
But second thing is just the vast distance
between me and the front of the windshield
and then I just straight up
can't see the front of the car.
I can't see the nose no
matter how high I look.
That's just different, very different.
Something I'm gonna have to get used to.
Okay, love that the button blinkers
are actually physical buttons
and now we're on a bit of a crazier road
so we can...
(car buzzing quietly)
Holy, come on.
That's crazy.
Actually, the suspension
pretty firm right now
and there is a large delta
between the firmest suspension
and the softest suspension
that you can have.
The body itself, thanks
to the stainless steel,
thanks to the way it's built is very,
very stiff, torsionally stiff.
It's very rigid.
And so all of that effort
to be either soft or firm
goes on the suspension
and they have a really good suspension,
really good travel, really fast travel.
It really is very quiet.
Okay, a couple other interesting
things that you note.
One is like huge amount of glass,
world's largest windshield
is pretty funny.
I think with every Tesla I've reviewed
for the past couple years,
there's always been one
muscle memory remap required
to get used to this thing.
And I think with previous Teslas,
like we all know about the center screen,
you're used to checking right
in front of you for the speed.
Now you have to look over to the side.
Just a little remap there.
With the yolk steering wheel
and the buttons on the steering wheel,
that's a remap people have to adjust to.
They're pretty stubborn about this stuff.
With this one, it's gonna be that there
is no rear visibility with the mirror
when the tonneau cover's closed.
So my tonneau cover's closed right now,
can't see anything behind me,
but I've sort of started to
remap my glance behind me
to the preview of the rear facing camera,
which is on the screen all the time.
And so I just keep glancing
there to see what's behind me.
You can actually move it to
the left or right hand side
so you get a bigger preview
when it's on the right
or you can just move it on the left.
So yeah, that's the Cybertruck.
Muscle memory remap is
your rear view mirror
doesn't have a camera mode.
So if you wanna check behind you
while the tonneau cover's closed,
you're looking down there.
All right, we got a nice
little highway coming up.
I like instinctively put my
hand on this side of the wheel
to get ready for a big turn.
- Oh my god.
- But I don't have to do it
because it's so little.
It's a little turn.
All right, let's get on the highway.
So you don't need a ton of horsepower
for regular pickup truck stuff,
but merging onto a highway,
makes a lot of sense.
Let me get some space between
the car in front of me.
Oh my God, on all season
tires, all terrain tires.
Shouldn't be able to do that.
A couple other interesting
things though about this truck.
One, world's largest
windshield wiper is hilarious.
It looks ridiculous.
It might be logistically ridiculous too.
I don't know if in the ice or the snow,
if it's gonna be able to like break apart
enough ice to move that
huge windshield wiper.
There's probably a much
bigger motor to move it,
but it works.
So Neil, if you're wondering,
it doesn't quite cover
the entire windshield,
but it does go above my head
and cover 75% of what the
passenger's gonna see too.
So I feel like it's working at least.
And then the other thing to
note is for your road tripping
totally compatible with all
the Tesla superchargers,
it has all of the autopilot
stuff that other Teslas have,
but it's also now an
800 volt architecture.
And what that basically means
is it's able to charge
faster at V4 superchargers
and it's able to make total wires thinner.
because they conduct better
and they're more efficient.
And so the total wire
weight of the car goes down
for all of the high voltage systems.
It also has a 48 volt low voltage system,
which is four times the normal 12 volts
you'd see in most cars.
So in general this is,
it feels future proof
for that reason, but it'll
still charge just the same
as any other Tesla V3
and V2 superchargers.
A little more road noise too,
you notice in a little more,
a little more all-terrain tread
coming through to the cabin.
These bespoke tires I'm
told do have foam in them,
but you can still hear it and feel it.
Tiny bit of steering feel, that's weird.
Teslas are usually pretty numb,
but this does have some steering feel.
Now probably the funniest,
most interesting option
that I'm told about with this truck
is the extended battery option.
So all the cyber trucks will have
the same 123 kilowatt hour battery size.
But as we all know, long road trips
and towing and hauling things especially
takes a toll on your battery.
So there will be an optional battery,
an add-on battery that
you put in the trunk
that adds 120 miles of range.
It also adds a ton of weight
'cause now you're hauling
around a huge battery,
but now you have close to a
400, 450 mile range truck,
which might be what people need
to haul big things if
they're gonna work with it.
It's interesting.
I really feel like the biggest
strength of the Cybertruck
is it's gotta be the
power, the sheer force
of 2.7 seconds, zero to
60, 850 ish horsepower
like no other truck moves
in a straight line like this one does.
But I'm also gonna include
the steering as a pro,
you gotta get used to it.
But again, that tight turning radius
and how nimble it feels like on a highway
that's remarkably responsive.
Like I can turn my wheel
like this in a Model S Plaid
and it does not feel
as responsive as this.
That's a crazy thing to say.
So then it's downside is gonna be one,
just that people think
it's ugly and that's fine.
A lot of people are gonna think it's ugly.
And two is it's more expensive
than we originally thought.
It doesn't have that price advantage.
I am driving a hundred thousand
dollars truck right now.
There's no way around that.
The F-150 Lightning
I'm following right now
is gonna cost significantly less.
The Rivian R1T and the and the Hummer
are also very expensive,
but it's no longer an advantage
that we might have
thought it was gonna be.
Now this isn't a review.
I haven't towed anything with this.
I haven't used any of
the trailer features.
I haven't filled it up with rocks
and mud and gotten it dirty.
I haven't off roaded at all.
There's a total separate off-road mode
in the thing I haven't used.
I haven't road tripped in it.
I haven't lived with it.
I do have an order so I
plan on doing all that.
So make sure you get subscribed
to see the full review of the
Cybertruck when it comes out.
But I think generally, as this
is my second impressions ever
and first time ever driving the thing,
I think they really got
themselves something solid here.
We're gonna have to see
about fit and finish.
A lot of, let's see,
a lot of wait and see,
but I'm impressed with this.
I'm impressed.
So lemme know what you think.
Obviously, there're gonna be
some polarizing thoughts on the looks.
Let me know if you're in the,
this thing is ugly and
I'll never buy it camp.
Why is this thing looking like
a stainless steel refrigerator on wheels?
I totally get it,
but lemme know what you
think about Cybertruck
versus F-150 Lightning versus Rivian R1T.
Let me know if there are other things
you want to see in a video
then get subscribed to me
among the first to see that stuff.
I think that's about it for this one.
Thanks for watching.
Catch you later, peace.
(upbeat music)